More cocaine wine?
- Yes.
- A little bit more won't hurt.
Any lady in Newport society
needs to know how
to hold her liquor.
Well, I can hold my liquor
better than anyone!
Me, too!
Oh, my goodness,
that sounds like a challenge.
Shall we see who can drink it
the fastest?
- Oh!
- Yes! Yes!
Helen, other person!
- Let's race.
- One, two, three go!
Wait! I have to tell Helen
we're doing a contest.
Come on.
(Marquis de Sainsbury)
Go, go, go, go, go.
Aah!
You are all piles of trash!
I am a mountain of gold!
I won! I took the egg!
Aah!
I won, you dumb haybag!
You don't count.
Second place.
Why am I always second place?
You're not second place.
Lillian's second place!
I'm first place.
I won.
No one asked you to play, Hore!
You're fat!
"Other person"?!
I'm the one that taught her
to communicate!
Without me she'd be nothing!
You're nothing
without me, Keller!
Nothing!
I love you, Annie!
Aah!
[screams]
That's a Ming vase,
you deaf bitch!
We only have 17 of those!
[screams]
[screaming]
I wasn't totally sure
what was happening...
Aah!
but I knew I wanted
to stab someone.
[screaming]
Let go of my sister!
You heathens!
What is this, Baltimore?!
[gunshot]
[screams]
Intruder!
Wawa.